foreign
[Music]
so here's the first thing
admit that your life is a mess
beckon
and this one's a bit tougher okay
you ready
here it is
you don't want to get out of it
you do not want to get out of the mess
talk to any psychologist who's worth his
name and it'll confirm that
the last thing a client wants
is a cure
he doesn't want to get cured
he wants relief
Eric Bernay one of the great
psychiatrists here in the United States
put it very graphically
he suggested you imagine a client who's
up to his nose in a cesspool
he calls it liquid excrement
and he's coming to the doctor
and you know what he says to the doctor
foreign
could you help me
so that people don't make waves
[Music]
the client does not want to get out of
the cesspool
oh no no no no get out For Heaven's Sake
no
just help me so they won't make waves
that's what he wants
he doesn't want to get out
you want to test that on yourself
I'll give you a couple minutes you could
do it right now
okay
here goes
suppose you could be blissfully happy
but you're not going to get that college
degree
are you ready to barter your degree for
happiness
you're not going to get that girlfriend
of yours or that boyfriend
are you ready to barter them for
happiness
huh
how about this
you're not going to be a success
you're gonna fail
everyone is going to call you a bum
but you'll be happy
you'll be blissfully happy
are you ready to barter the good opinion
of other people
for that
I'll give you time to think about it
later
when I was in Syracuse last summer I saw
something in the newspaper it was an
advertisement showing a girl holding on
to a boy and she says
I don't want to be happy
the only happy people I know
are in a lunatic asylum
I want to be miserable with you
see what I mean
I don't want to be happy I want to be
miserable with you
she'll develop a theology about the damn
thing after a while
[Music]
people don't want to get out of it they
don't want it I don't want happiness I
want fame
and I don't want happiness I want to get
that gold medal at the Olympics
suppose I tell you look
give up the gold medal you'll be happy
damn it
what do you want that gold for anyway
why do you want to be at the top the
boss of the corporation
I'll make you happy
on ten thousand dollars a year I'll make
you happy
it's from the 80s so you probably have
to adjust for inflation
it's probably 36k now
return the text
no no no no no give me my money my money
my money my money
see what I mean now
you're catching on
people don't want to be happy
[Music]
I'll tell you what it means to live like
a king
to know no anxiety at all to have no
inner Conflict at all no tensions no
pressures
no upset
no heartache
so then what are you left with
happiness undiluted
people sometimes say
what do I do
to be happy
you don't do anything to be happy silly
it shows how bad your education has been
if you think you've got to do something
to be happy
you don't have to do anything
you can't acquire happiness
you know why
because you have it
you've got it right now
but the whole time you're blocking it
with your stupidity
you're blocking it stop blocking it
and you'll have it
if I could show you how to get rid of
your conflicts your anxieties your
tensions your pressures your emptiness
your loneliness
your despair
your depression
[Music]
your heartache
if you could get rid of all that
what are you left with
sheer undiluted happiness
that's what you would have
[Music]
the Chinese put it beautifully when the
eye is unobstructed they say
the result
is sight
don't do anything to get sight
when the eye is unobstructed
[Music]
the result is sight
when the ear is unobstructed the result
is hearing when the mouth is
unobstructed the result is taste when
the mind is unobstructed
[Music]
the result
is truth
and when the heart is unobstructed ah
the result is joy and love
you've got it all
but it's obstructed
you can drop it
so
the second major step
recognize that you don't want to get out
of it
you want comfort
you want your little possessions
you want the little things that Society
has falsely taught you are essential for
happiness
you want that
you don't want to get out of the mess
those are the things that are creating
the mess
I'm gonna give you something to think
about
has it ever occurred to you that
what you call your happiness
is really your chain
for example
are you calling somebody your happiness
as in
you are my joy
it could be your marriage your business
your degree your job whatever
in whom do you find your happiness
[Music]
whatever the answer is
that is your prison
[Music]
oh
that is Harsh language but
reflect on these words
and here's the third thing
your life is in a mess because you have
wrong ideas
it's not because there's anything wrong
with you
you're okay I'm okay you're okay we're
all okay
we're great there's nothing wrong with
us
but they they put the wrong ideas in our
heads
[Music]
somebody did we need to spend too much
time trying to catch the culprit
but anyway
we have the wrong ideas
you know if somebody has given you a
stereo set
then you received a manual of
instructions along with it
well
they didn't give us a manual
when they gave us the gift of life
or
let's put it another way
they gave us the manual of instructions
but it was all wrong
so you're not getting music
you're getting scratchy sounds
you're getting upset
you're getting conflicts
you're getting loneliness
you're getting emptiness
oh
it's right there in the Bible the Quran
the Hindu texts the Buddha every but
very few people read it
they think they do but they miss the
point
I missed the point
maybe I'm an unusually big idiot
but I discovered lots of company
they missed the point too
they didn't get it
all right so what is
the point
now
there are many ways of putting forth the
formula I'm going to give you the
simplest I've found
I'm going to give it to you in the words
of old Buddha
why did I choose him
because his words are the simplest of
all
but you find the formula everywhere
it's proclaimed with clarity
you're probably going to disagree with
it
but you can't miss the point
you ready
here it is
the world is full of Sorrow
the root of Sorrow
is desire
the uprooting of Sorrow
is
desirelessness
oh I'm imagining your faces it's
wonderful you're thinking
that's great that's great but then
you're thinking
wrong that's awful
[Music]
isn't it wonderful because
I know how I used to react to this
the world is full of Sorrow great right
agreed
the root of Sorrow is desire well all
right
now what are you going to conclude
the uprooting of Sorrow
is desirelessness
so what I'm gonna be a vegetable I mean
how do we live
without desires
let me give you a better translation
I don't think the Buddha would have been
so foolish and stupid as to say that we
ought not have any desires For Heaven's
Sake I wouldn't be speaking if I didn't
have the desire to speak
you wouldn't be here if you didn't have
the desire to come and hear me
so
let's give it a better translation
the world
is full of Sorrow
the root of Sorrow
is attachment
the uprooting of Sorrow means the
uprooting
the dropping of attachments
you know
there are desires on Whose fulfillment
my happiness does not depend in fact
you've got lots of desires on Whose
fulfillments fulfillment your happiness
does not depend
or else
you'd be climbing walls
you'd be nervous wrecks
we all of us have two types of desires
we've got some desires we desire all
kinds of things and gee we're happy to
get them
but when we don't get them
it's okay
too bad
we're not unhappy
but we've got other desires good Lord if
we don't get them we're going to be
miserable
that's what I mean by attachment
where do you think all conflicts come
from
attachment
where do you think greed comes from
attachments
where do you think loneliness comes from
where do you think emptiness comes from
you got it same calls
what do you think fear comes from
attachments no attachments
no fear
ever thought of that
no attachments
no fear
[Music]
attachment
is the enemy of love
you see
you're really confronting a choice
between life and death and what people
call life as frequently death
though they don't know it
and you mean to tell me that if you've
got attachments
think you can love
the biggest enemy of Love is attachment
desire in the sense of attachment you
know why
because if I desire you
I want to possess you
I can't leave you free
I've got to get you I've got to
manipulate you so that I can get you
if I desire you in this way
I'm going to manipulate myself so I can
Hoodwink you into allowing me to get you
are you following what I'm saying
there is no fear
and perfect love
you know why
because there is no desire
now
ask your culture
I've asked mine
ask your culture if they can make any
sense out of this
where there is love
there is no desire
that's desire in the sense of attachment
you know
you know what they will tell you
[Music]
but attachment is love
that's how stupid we are expecting to
find life here
I could find only death
and misery
an attachment
such a simple such a Sublime such an
extraordinary thing I run into people of
all kinds religious and non-religious
people people who are atheists or
whatever and Catholics or lay people
priests and sisters and Bishops and I
rarely run into someone who knows
What Love Is
they all got the wrong instructions
attachment means
I gotta get you
it means without you
I will not be happy if I don't get you
I won't be happy I cannot be happy
without you there
you've got the formula for divorce
there you've got the formula for
quarrels
there
you've got the formula for friendships
falling apart
I cannot be happy without you
I need you for my happiness by damn I'll
do everything to manipulate you
to get you
love means
on the other hand
love means I'm perfectly happy without
you
it's all right
it means
and I wish you good and I leave you free
and when I get you
I'm delighted
and when I don't
I'm not miserable
well
what do you know
I have learned to be self-sufficient
I'm standing up on my own two feet
not leaning on you and you know if I
give money
that's wonderful
but if I don't give money
I'm not depressed
I'm still happy
you know something else
when you go away
I don't
and and maybe it's too soon to say this
here
but I'll risk it
when you go away
I don't miss you
I don't feel pain
where there is sorrow
there is no love
tell me
when you grieve
whom are you grieving for
whose loss
grieving
self-pity
oh don't call it that
you're telling the truth now
here's a secret here's a secret formula
for you
you were not actively engaged in making
yourself miserable
you would be happy
you see
we were born happy
all of life is shot through with
happiness
oh there's pain of course there's pain
who told you that you can't be happy
with pain
come and meet a friend of mine who's
dying of cancer
she's happy and in pain
so
we were born happy
we lost it
we were born with the gift of life
[Music]
and we lost it
we've got to ReDiscover it
why did we lose it
because
we were at working actively
they taught us to work actively to make
ourselves miserable
how did they do that
by teaching us to become attached
by teaching us to have desires so
intense that we would refuse to be happy
unless they were fulfilled
the tragedy is that you need the tragedy
is that all you need to do
is sit down for two minutes
and just watch how untrue that
assumption is that you would be unhappy
without a or b or X or Y or
whatever
you know something
you won't sit
because if you sit
you might see it
you won't sit and look at it
I know I wouldn't
I resisted it for years
you mean if I don't get married or I
don't get John I won't be happy hey wait
a minute come to think of it
you're right before I met her or before
I met him
I was happy
[Music]
you know something
I once fell in love with somebody and
then well
I lost her
I was heartbroken
and what happened
I'm all right now
so she wasn't my happiness
remember the time that you were a child
and you lost something
and you thought
I'll never be happy without this
what happened
if we gave it to you today
[Music]
you wouldn't even look at it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
family and friends
enemies and allies
the minimalist
[Applause]
[Music]
s
every little thing that's just feeding
your dreams
cheers what's up y'all
thanks for being here this is awesome
yeah
how about Kelly's little sound bath to
start us off Give It Up
oh that was stunning we were backstage
in TK you were like any future event she
has to be here
yeah I was like no more future events if
she's not
let's talk a bit about that reading um I
wanted to start off with that because
I wasn't really reading it to you it's
like me reading it to myself as a
reminder and you just happen to be here
to witness it
but I think this is the thing that we
all struggle with people come to us
because of consumerism but that's a type
of attachment we're seeking to fill the
void the emptiness
and we don't realize that
what we're actually doing is widening
the void making things worth creating
new attachments in our lives so initial
Impressions on what I just read there by
the way that was from Anthony Demello
yeah I mean when you were reading I was
thinking about how I agree like the more
we attach ourselves to things the the
more we open ourselves up to being
disappointed hurt
angry sad all the all the negative
emotions
um I started to think how attachments is
really it's kind of a synonym with
expectation isn't it yeah I think so I
mean I loved the distinction he made
like we have these two types of desires
and maybe if I were to break it down a
little bit I would say the attachment
has to do with the expectation I want a
particular outcome and if I don't get
that outcome I don't get that person
that paycheck that job that
accomplishment that trophy that car that
dress whatever it might be then I'm
miserable I will be unhappy right that's
an expectation right but then there's
this other type of desire which is just
like this is compelling or I'm attracted
to this it could be writing for someone
but whenever I write it has very little
to do with the outcome in fact whenever
my writing becomes outcome based like a
publisher is like you must turn in this
book by the it makes the writing
miserable because all of a sudden you're
now attaching an expectation to it but
there's this other side where it's like
I'm just really attracted to this like
these events we've been super attracted
to doing these events and that's why we
do it yeah I think it maps on very well
to the distinction between consumption
and creativity because consumption is
always about going after something that
is outside of myself and depending upon
it for my survival whereas creativity is
about bringing forth something that is
within and that's a very different kind
of Joy I need that or I will die versus
there's something I must Express because
this is what makes me come alive and
consumption is valid for some things
right I do need water I do need food or
I will die but the advertising industry
convinces us that that is also true of a
host of other things I need that product
or I will socially die I need that car
or I will professionally die and they
Orient us towards consumption feeling
like I need something outside of myself
to be a player in the game of life and
the joy of being human is to tap into
that creativity because that's what
makes us human right it's what is within
me that I need to bring forth and as a
way of saying hey I'm here this is an
artifact or an experience that
represents my joy
yeah it's like all the all the little
bits of input we get with advertisements
you know the five to ten ten thousand
ads we see a day it's like it muddles
that that genuine um desire for what you
want to put out there I'm like so
fascinated with the AI stuff
um it's like I love talking about it and
thinking about it I think like we're in
a really cool time right now and it'll
either like save everyone's lives or it
will kill us all I'm I'm I'm voting for
the for the uh the former
um I uh but I was I was reading an
article the other day about how
the AI is gonna get so good it's already
there they have apps that do this but
just with the camera they can like look
at your pupils they can look at how wide
your eyes are like they can get so much
data just from some like biometric stuff
that they get from the camera
and they will start to
manipulate manipulate you and you won't
even realize it wait what do you mean
like it's reacting to your your
um your bios so like it will start to
feed you things based upon the mood that
you're in essentially they're gonna take
over the world but
well go ahead what you're saying there
is is exactly what I was reading here
but it's Amplified tremendously right
and that's why it's important we
understand this because when we feel
these broken expectations
when we feel incomplete because we don't
have something like we have to
understand like that that tug of uh
you know that the ad agencies have on us
like we really have to be clear that
um our desires are our desires not
something that has been fed to us right
and it's hard to differentiate that and
it's only going to get harder
I had a weird realization I was walking
over here I stayed at a hotel last night
um and I was just walking over here it's
a very long walk and as I was walking
the thought that popped into my head and
I was hoping we'd have an opportunity to
talk about it but it echoes exactly what
you're saying here is
and this is hard to say but I think it's
true
you will never get what you want
and let me expand on that a little bit
because
we often think we want something but
it's not what
we want it's what someone else wants for
us now advertisers are it's easy to make
them the boogeyman which we often do you
know we think advertisements suck we
don't like advertisements and and yet so
the desires that we have become these
memetic desires I saw it in a magazine
or I saw an influencer wearing it or I
saw it on YouTube or I just saw someone
walking down the street and they looked
good in that shirt or with that purse or
whatever it was and now I want it the
thing that I didn't even realize
was available to me I feel like I
couldn't live without it now
I want it so much
okay that's one kind of one
and we all know intellectually like
getting that isn't going to complete me
or whatever but there are some deeper
things that you truly want
and you'll get them sometimes
when I say you won't get what you want
because what the thing you want is never
actually the thing you want
the thing you want is the feeling is
behind the thing right the promotion the
consumer purchase the relationship you
want the feeling behind that even some
virtuous Pursuits I really want to
contribute to my community I want to
build wells in Africa I want to build
orphanages right
great
but the thing you want is actually
behind the thing that you want
and the problem with getting what you
want is
we try to hold on to that thing
and if you hold on to the thing
that you wanted you got it but as you
hold on to it you cling to it what
happens you cease to one in fact it
becomes a burden
I had the weirdest dream last night
I was walking around with this giant it
wasn't like a boulder but it was a very
big rock about the size of one of these
balloons up here it was a heavy Rock
and in the dream Ryan was there was my
shirt on
it was a that was a different dream
a fantasy one might say
you have to be sleep for a Dream
we are bifurcating
I was carrying this giant I was walking
carrying this giant rock around and Ryan
just shows up on the street and I'm
carrying it and he's like hey man that
looks heavy this is just last night
yeah it is
he goes why'd you pick it up I said I
needed to pick it up he goes okay
because you know you can set it down
and it was just this Revelation like
I can set this down
but that isn't that true with the
expectations you were talking about yeah
well because the whole time you're
reading that I was thinking about all
the expectations I've had in my life and
the different attachments and the
desires and things that I've chased and
so many of them like I hadn't I didn't
even realize I picked them up
and it's easy to say and easy to
understand if you want to be truly happy
which
happiness is even we could talk about
that for an hour but for the for the the
sake of the the context here like to be
happy you have to let go of all your
desires let go of all your attachments
easy to say easy to understand but
man we pick them up so so many times
without even realizing that we're doing
it
and it's not until we start to feel that
discontent that
whatever negative emotion it's creating
then then we have the opportunity to
kind of Let It Go rather than try to
it's I think it's harder to try and not
pick up anything because it's just they
just happen naturally and that was the
thing in the dream
yes I knew I was carrying it but didn't
really realize that I picked it up that
it was just a part of my everyday
walking at that point and yes I knew I
had it but I didn't know what it was
doing to me but as soon as you see
that attachment that expectation for
what it is that's the only time you can
actually let it go I remember our last
Sunday Symposium there was a woman in
the back she asked a question
about how do I let go of something I
remember what it was and my answer was
hey the microphone you're holding
if that was a snake would you be asking
me how to Let It Go
and she said well no I said well what
would you do because she wouldn't come
to anyone and say
I need help letting this go I need a
three-step plan a method of Technology
whatever no because as soon as you see
the problem
that's when you have the ability to
actually drop it and that's why I wanted
to read that that intro today
uh Robert Fritz and a very excellent
book called The Path of least resistance
he talks about this idea of how we
typically rely on a process to give us
the faith to move our lives towards a
result and so we say unless I have a way
to lose weight I'm not going to lose
weight and so we wait on someone to
provide us with a process and then we
make the decision to lose weight and he
says it is the decision about the what
that gives rise to the how it's not
until you decide I'm going to be healthy
I'm going to quit smoking I'm going to
increase my income whatever it may be
that you actually get a process that can
take you there but if you seek
permission from processes what will
happen is you'll always find something
missing in the process because there is
no process that's created for you right
processes have to be created by you as a
result of committing to some end result
but I wanted to get back to that desire
thing because my wife Shelly and I we
like to watch a lot of True Crime and we
were watching this uh we like to get
into arguments over like what's going to
happen and like who did it and stuff
like that
in another life we would be uh private
private detectives or lawyers or
something like that maybe in this life
who knows I always try and convince my
wife Bex to um to go out and stake out
with me
hahaha
I just want to sit in the car and like
spy on people
I don't know what that says about me I
don't I'm not on a particular outcome I
just want to I just want to watch you
that might be a true crime documentary
unto itself
so there's this one about this con
artist and I think it's something like
chasing the ghost
and he manages to convince so many
people that he's like the spy and so on
and so there's this one family where
he's uh the mother has two uh two kids
and they're both kind of like teenagers
and and he moves in he gets really close
to the mother the father's already
separated but everyone's on amicable
terms and what he needs to do is
alienate the children from their father
in order to further his efforts at
manipulation and so every single day he
tells the daughter he says you don't
like your father do you
and you know she's just like yeah I like
my dad but every day he says it to her
you don't really like your father do you
yeah you don't really like him and she's
the one telling the story and she says
every single day multiple times a day
she's got this man saying you don't like
your father do you yeah I can tell you
don't like your father and at some point
it just clicked and she internalized
that and was just like yeah I don't
really like my dad and the dad was out
of the picture and he was able to
entrench himself further into the family
and eventually separate the mother from
the children and then just take his
manipulation even further but it just
sort of illustrates in this really
powerful and tragic way how easily we
can internalize someone else's value
system someone else's likes and dislikes
and we see it playing out every day when
we go to social media and we say hey uh
who should I be angry at who should I be
offended by who should I hate today who
should I be afraid of today and social
media media is like really good at
studying what you click on and what
makes you feel emotion which is why
whenever you say things like hey
everybody no one pay attention to this
this made me so mad today the machine
says thank you for your business because
it doesn't care if you give it attention
based on hate or based on love you know
it's like if I'm going through the
grocery store and I you know see
something I go ugh that's gross and I
put it in my car and pay for it the
company's like thank you for your
business they don't care if I bought it
out of hate and that's what we do right
we just put everything into our cart but
social media is really good
at like catering to our taste and it'll
say hmm
okay I see what you're clicking on hey
check this out here's a video of five
black people jumping this white kid and
calling him racial slurs you over there
here's a video of five white people
jumping this black kid and calling them
racial slurs I'm gonna separate you all
and put you in this world and I'm gonna
put you in this virtual world because I
need you to be scared of them and I need
you to be scared of them I need you to
think this person's great I need you to
think this person's evil and every day
we get fed these stories because we're
not creating our own news we're not
informing ourselves based on our own
priorities and our own principles but
we're getting our instructions from this
world that is incentivized to get us to
behave in any way that feeds the machine
and so we have all of these desires and
all of these values that don't even
belong to us and how long until we wake
up and say wait a minute
of these dreams are even mine none of
these fears are even mine none of these
questions that are holding me back are
even mine I don't need those answers
those are somebody else's questions I
can be free to live my life with what I
know and what I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's
I totally agree with everything you just
said I think in some ways it's even more
pernicious than that because
I think that
if you are consuming content on social
media to use some really vapid phrases
um like whatever happened to reading or
listening it's it's consuming content
like even our approach to engaging the
world is very machine-like anyway go
ahead a friend of mine pointed out
something at our studio there's our
neighbor is a general contractor the
construction company there and he has a
sign up for UPS
and on there it says content has no
value
and uh
that's a quite the the profound message
but uh I think it just meant that you
can leave these boxes here on my
doorstep they're not worth anything
anyway with with social media
and I was like yeah you're right yeah
content does have no value
almost anything
um
but
I think the it's even worse than hey if
you like it and you click on it
that's one thing but if you hate it it's
the same thing I would say well no
because if you truly are at peace
you're probably going to turn off the
app or turn off the phone or set it down
but if you're
yearning for more more and more the
disease of more I need more dopamine I
need more attention I need more clicks
whatever it might be you get that
through discontent and so in a way
social media incentivizes discontent
it incentivizes
our unhappiness
and it incentivizes us seeking out those
things
because we confuse the dopamine Rush
with happiness
and then it becomes this digital prison
that we have in our pockets and we carry
around with us every day
well that makes me think about the
reading that you did and how
the so like Twitter and Facebook all the
other social media companies they don't
they don't say they don't meet in a
boardroom and they're like okay we're
gonna feed everyone angry sad things
today right it is a algorithm
that
that just pairs with us in our in what
we View and what we continue to come
back to and so it makes me think about
the reading because if all we're getting
in our social media feeds are the things
that we're talking about right now
that's because we want it
it's because we are feeding it that
information so of course it's going to
give us that stuff and if I was to ask
you know
um someone who super politically charged
angry if I asked him like do you want to
be angry all the time they would
probably say no I don't but it's just
unfortunate how the world is you know it
just makes me angry I have to they make
me angry
yeah it's which is like the biggest lie
right because no one here has the power
to make me angry only I can anger myself
right in reaction to this perceived
Injustice that I see from you it's it's
really fascinating most of my favorite
guests on the minimalist podcast are the
ones who are the most controversial and
oftentimes I don't even realize they're
controversial until Jessica starts
sending me all the comments for on on
the particular episode and I'm like oh
wow that medical doctor
um was really I didn't didn't have any
idea or that that psychiatrist was
really controversial I didn't know
people didn't like her and people get
really really upset and outraged and the
reason they do is they think that I and
Ryan and TK upset them it is our fault
that they are upset I'll dare us
like I came to their house with a bucket
of discontent and said here you go hold
on to this
but it's kind it's kind of like that
rock that I was carrying in the dream
right because the truth is that if I
carry that rock over and hand it to TK
I can hand it to him he can choose to to
take it from me but from what he does
with it from there is totally up to him
he could set it down he can run around
with it he can complain to me that I
handed him this damn Rock and why would
you do this to me if if we were friends
you wouldn't hand me a boulder you
wouldn't do this to me
like oh man I thought you wanted it
why don't you just just set it down
but we choose to be
silent about our pain you know uh who
was it uh
Zora Neil Hurston said if if you were
silent about your pain people will kill
you and say you enjoyed it
that's what happens when you give other
people power over your narrative I I
have a question for you guys though
based on what you just said
um if we don't want this why do we
choose it so like if social media is
showing me things that are a reflection
of what I'm choosing but you ask me in
theory do I want to be angry today my
answer is no why am I choosing that why
do we choose things we don't want
I think that's the million dollar
question man I think that's why Josh
read that reading is because it is hard
to understand
I mean of course no one wants to be
angry but
that algorithm is reflecting what you
want yeah I don't know the answer to
that I think the first line that I
started with was
you don't want to get out of this mess
and I think that's why ultimately
because getting out of the mess means
letting go of all of these attachments
these expectations these false desires
these beliefs these opinions that make
us who we are
my favorite quotes is from ROM Das and
someone was asking him this woman was
asking him a question and one and uh
setting not dissimilar from this
and she said
I'm just trying to find
what aligns with my personality I'm
trying to find the activities they'll
align with my identity
he said oh that's cute
you think you have an identity
um
and yes we have identities but we've
created them they're they're
self-contained and we Adorn ourselves
with business titles here's the here's
what it says on my business card here's
Who I Am What do you do is the first
question we ask someone when we meet
them and they give you a business title
or they tell you what they enjoy or I'm
a mother I'm a fight you go to the
someone's bio on Twitter and it says uh
husband father Christian Author whatever
and all of a sudden it's like is that
all you are no obviously not right
and there's nothing wrong with those
things and understanding something about
a person but their approximations
of who we are they're not who we
actually are
Ken Wilbur does a lot of work on this he
calls it no boundary awareness where he
talks about basically whenever we um say
this is who I am or this is what I am
we're essentially drawing a boundary
around us that says I am not that right
so a self-definition is a way of saying
what you are not when I say I am TK uh I
am a black American male or I am a
Christian or I am from Chicago I'm
telling you what I'm not I am not Josh I
am not that desk I am not an inanimate
object right
um I am not a child and the funny thing
about these boundary lines is that over
time we find that they're far more
negotiable than we typically expect we
say things like I'm just not a people
person I'm just not a normal I'm just
not a normal person Freudian slip amen
I'm just not a morning person right but
then maybe you get this job that
requires you to get up at five in the
morning or maybe you marry someone or
you have children and it requires you to
make adjustments and you realize oh this
quality I accepted to be as you know
part of my self-definition it's actually
quite negotiable and I'm glad to let it
go and over time you find that that
boundary line gets bigger and bigger and
the question that Ken Wilbur is always
challenging challenging us to ask
ourselves is where does that boundary
line really end
and and why should we assume that it has
an end and maybe it does but the end
might not be the same as where it
happens to fall right now because life
is always challenging us to do that one
other thing I wanted to say about the
desire question is uh there's an
important economics concept that I think
can help with these sorts of things and
it's basically what's called stated
versus revealed preference and stated
preference is what a person says they
want so you find out people's stated
preferences when you conduct surveys
like hey if this guy ran for office
would you vote for him yeah if Ryan
became a rock star and had a concert
tomorrow night would you go yeah if
right so stated preference is what I
genuinely feel I would do revealed
preferences what I actually choose when
scarcity or sacrifice is involved
so stated preferences basically if I had
the power to wave a magic wand and give
you whatever you wanted without any cost
or responsibilities or sacrifices on
your end would you say yes to it that's
basically what stated preference is and
it doesn't mean that we're lying it just
means people make different choices when
there's no sacrifice or responsibility
involved and the choices we make in life
are not a reflection of what we want in
theory but their reflection of what
we're willing to sacrifice or prioritize
so right now in this moment my stated
preference is I want ice cream right now
and I'm not lying in this moment I want
ice cream and that's real but in order
to make that happen
I have to do something and I have to I
have to take a risk of some kind I gotta
go hey guys I'm really loving this show
right now
but can you give me like a 15 minute
break and I'll be back I gotta go get
some ice cream and it's like hmm
when I compare my desire for ice cream
with what's entangled in that I'm gonna
say no to it today at this time right
and so our life is a reflection of our
priorities not our preferences it's not
our wishes it's not the things that we
say we want but it's what we're willing
to choose when we have to let something
else go
and
hey I'll take it I'll take it
[Applause]
[Music]
no you know going back at least you
didn't say please clap right please clap
not to get political up here
um going back to the question you asked
about
why do we hold on to these things that
we don't want
it has something to do with the cost of
letting it go and living in a different
world yes because I think back to like
when I was
raised Jehovah's Witness I loved knowing
how the world worked how do we get here
let me tell you
why are we here right now oh I got
answers for that
you want to know where we're going
do you need to get your own planet right
yeah right exactly that's that's the
other religion oh yeah sorry but but the
thing like when I was disconnecting from
that though it was very difficult
because when when you have an
understanding of how the world works and
we all want that
um and when you're so sure about it and
then and then it starts to crumble a
little bit it's like I I had a choice it
was like do I go even you know go more
all in with it or do I like start to let
it unravel a little bit and to go more
all in was very tempting
it's like picking up more of those rocks
yeah yeah
um so you know what religion or not
political whatever situation people
are choosing to make themselves
miserable in it has it has to do with I
think
that's their world view and to to look
at it any other way is risking
their
it's it's risking them being right like
they they don't want to be no one wants
to be wrong about how they look at the
world view so if they start to look at
it in a different way they are giving up
that certainty and if they've been wrong
the whole time because I went through it
I mean at 25 years old I'm like
like I have been like just bullshitting
me and everyone else for the last 25
years it's hard to admit that
yeah you know this is why
we have to be so careful with trying to
change other people
even if we are convinced that the advice
we have for them is better than the
ideas they're currently acting on I'm
not saying you can never exercise
influence but you got to be very careful
because people's ideas are not just
these theoretical beliefs they have
they're not just answers that they would
give on a philosophy test or a theology
exam people's worldview holds their
whole self together they build their
family life around these World Views
their daily routines around these World
Views and if you take something away
from someone
what are you going to replace that with
and people have to grow and evolve in
their own time and at their own pace not
because your ideas you want to influence
what them with don't matter but because
everyone needs to go at a different pace
with integrating new insights into their
world view because if you ask someone to
change too quickly you might destroy
them there is no such thing as a piece
of advice that is so good that it can't
be abused or misapplied in a way that
actually makes your life worse and
that's why we have to be careful related
I saw a friend on Facebook posts the
following I'm going to paraphrase it
because I can't quote it but
he says something to the effect of
I got together with a friend of mine the
other day and this friend is someone who
claims to be religious but sometimes I
see him living in ways that are not
consistent with his religion and there
are other days I see him living in a
very Noble and devout way
and I had a moment where I wanted to
call him out on it but I also knew that
if he discovers the truth for himself
and sees it for himself he'll be more
likely to make the improvements so
instead I looked at him I told him that
I loved him and I asked him if I could
pray with him and after that I winked at
him and decided to walk away from the
mirror
[Applause]
well thank you all for coming today
let's open it up for some questions
assume Alabama roaming somewhere where
is she she's sneaking in the back hi
everybody ladies and gentlemen Alabama
so we're really here for you so whatever
questions you might have if you want to
talk about why you're here today or what
your expectations are
Mallory will uh take care of you please
hi there my name is Barbara all right
y'all that's our minimal episode for
today what a magical event if you'd like
to listen to the back half of this sold
out Sunday Symposium our final Sunday
Symposium you can check out the maximal
edition of episode 387 on the
minimalists private podcast that private
podcast episode includes the entire q a
section plus some additional minimalist
insights and one more special reading
from that live event head on over to
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one and if you leave here today with
just one message please let it be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it